welcome back
they're putting the harris in harris
meant
i like that and i know it's bad
yes it's another one of kamala's roles
battling online trolls addressing
disinformation is her newest order
despite not fixing anything at the
border
on thursday day of the week cat
the white house announced the launch of
yet another new board to be led by vp
kamala harris it's being called a task
force to address online harassment and
abuse
but the other working title is a task
force to keep this crazy cackling psycho
away from a microphone
very long
so
the memo says its mission will be
focused on quote developing programs and
policies to address online harassment
abuse disinformation campaigns targeting
women and
lgbtqi plus
individuals who are public and political
figures government and civic leaders
activists journalists in the united
states and globally
what an interesting choice of targets
why not just say people who might be
leftists
so it sounds like kamala is basically
now a twitter content moderator i guess
she'll have to take down her own jesse
smilet tweets
but as plenty of people have pointed out
this new task force sounds a lot like
the disinformation board the dhs tried
to roll out in april minus a loony
singing show tunes
tell us about it campster we still have
so much more work to do
to protect people
from online harassment and abuse
which is why the work of this task force
is so important
hmm well that was boring
let's add some bongos
we still have so much more work to do
to protect people
from online harassment and abuse
which is why the work of this task force
is so important
it's like them
much better
so what can we expect from this new task
force
well it also includes dhs secretary
alejandro mayorkas a.g merrick garland
and secretary of state anthony blinken
[Music]
wow they don't like them
i don't know about you guys
let's see how long these folks last they
held their first meeting on thursday i
believe we have tape
[Music]
deagan
how do you think they come up for jobs
with for a combo do they have like just
throw darts or is there a bingo card or
that little ball that
eight ball magic eight ball yeah
sometimes it's magic we ouija board yes
uh cause she's a whoa man and she's
gonna stand up for woe
men everywhere
i if she says she's on the case with
online harassment by the way melania
trump already did this so
yeah
uh
she could step stand up for me i have
this weird neck
this like
uh it's like it's this bony neck and it
looks like i have an adam's apple and so
people
um kind of attack me online about that
and call me a man it's usually the
people on the left calling me a man
which is transphobic so i would like to
put that at the top of her legs
and i'll tell you why because all of her
discoveries of harassment and
disinformation has to only go one way
right it's like
if you look i mean it will never come
from the left it only comes from the
right right tw yeah yeah and that's why
you see that everywhere everywhere and
that's why the democrat party is on life
support right now because what they've
done they've taken what should be human
rights and they try to divide us up into
different types of americans and
different types of rights there's only
one kind of rights and that's human
rights but they're not interested in
that right they're playing interested in
identity politics and it's exactly why
they're about to lose the house they're
about to lose the senate and in 2024
they're going to lose their presidency
because they've played this identity
politics to its very end and i think
americans are sick of it i know i am
just protect everybody
let's just protect everybody let's go
after harassment that's not that's fine
like if i only want to protect the
people i like i and the people i
disagree with screw them right cat
look i actually thought this memo as i
read it was like sexist and insulting
because
what it actually said was that seeing
comments from internet trolls is
something that's going to preclude women
from political decision-making about
their own lives so you think that me
seeing comments from internet trolls is
going to stop me from being able to make
decisions for myself because i'm a woman
like what kind of little [ __ ] does the
government think i am
because i'm a woman like i can handle it
you block or you just don't look at it
or any combination of both i'm going to
be fine i don't need this kind of help
yeah it's funny because when they talked
about who they were protecting they
meant they mentioned everybody and
everybody in there it made it sound like
they
they couldn't handle it wouldn't handle
it i found it insulting what are you
doing rob i'm just tweeting some means
about cat
that's it you're testing her cat doesn't
rain
doesn't really she doesn't read anything
but that's the problem first of all i
want to say
you are a very good looking man
i gotta say
your bigger mind
that is a that is a problem for both of
us
uh
it's hurt our
both of our careers would be better if
it was the other one
but i think one thing is that none of
this stuff is real yeah it isn't real
this harassment people i've been
harassing what do you mean we got
harassed online you went online
and you searched for mentions of
yourself
and then you read them all it's like why
would you read someone else's diary if
you know that they're writing in that
diary by the way greg really you don't
want it like this this is not real
people talk about oh i got death threats
you didn't get death
this is all bs and the weirdest thing is
the right of the moment in our culture
where we can know what everyone thinks
about us we become super sensitive yes
that's really not a very good thing
when this first started i was that
person and i go oh my god do i have
death threats well i'm if i if i go on
facebook and i look i'm gonna find them
and now every like now the death threat
excu the death threat defense is showing
up everywhere right it's like well i get
death like like if somebody like taylor
lorenz does something terrible right at
the washington post she gets called out
on right she goes but i got death
threats look someone told me to go jump
in the lake yes that's exactly like
that's not that's not a death threat
that's just a death suggestion yes
exactly
i don't know maybe she could swim i
don't know yeah that's true
she's an excellent swimmer
the person was telling her to get some
exercise
go jump in the lake they said because
they thought it would be good for her
long as you use the right pronoun you're
fine
that's all that matters
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else